We Begin only a few blocks away where
former president Trump was arraigned on
34 felony charges now yesterday for
allegedly mislabeling a couple of
documents basically now of course these
charges were cooked up and stacked by a
Manhattan D.A by the name Alvin Bragg if
you any fans here
[Music]
fellow political fantasy at campaign
promise which I have a big problem with
and like many liberals he dreams of
seeing Donald Trump in a orange jumpsuit
one big problem for Bragg his case is
totally Bogus the document charges at
play are misdemeanor infractions by the
way five years passed the statute of
limitations they were magically upgraded
to felonies by Bragg because of supposed
links to some mysterious Phantom crime
that he wouldn't even mention in the
indictment which we expect are likely
federal election law issues that both
the FEC and the doj looked at and passed
on now those are laws that are not in
Bragg's jurisdiction on top of that and
all again this this all surrounds a
legal non-disclosure agreement from what
seven years ago so despite this
pathetically weak convoluted case well
you have many Democrats who are
hopelessly suffering from Trump
derangement syndrome and now how they
are quivering they're upset they're sad
they're sad they may not see Donald
Trump in an orange jumpsuit take a look
regardless of what side what party
you're in regardless of anything it's
just really sad that a former president
is getting indicted well there is a
sadness I I think that we got to this
point in America well it is a sad day
for America it's a new low for the
American presidency it's not a
celebratory night it is a serious night
an a somber moment for our country
really this should be a somber moment
right I have a lot of friends on the on
the left side of the spectrum who are
doing a happy dance right now and I
don't think that's appropriate well
somebody today said you know this is a
very sad day and I think that is true
because you're seeing a former president
um in the dock okay they're all lying
and liberal Joe save us the phony tears
you're full of nothing but Adam
yeah end of the set
that was a somber moment but not because
of the serious nature of the charges far
left political hacks they were
officially now turning this great
country into a Banana Republic they're
stop stomping on our constitution
weaponizing Justice criminalizing
political differences in the country but
here's the good news for the first time
in a while Trump supporters and even
some Trump haters they're actually
coming together Donald Trump is uniting
the country at least some of us against
Bragg's idiotic destructive political
Witch Hunt look at this Mitt Romney he
hates Donald Trump but he released this
statement quote the prosecutor's
overreach sets a dangerous precedent for
criminalizing political opponents and
damages the Public's faith in our
justice system former Congressman Justin
Amash who enthusiastically voted to
impeach Donald Trump he tweeted Out
quote I am stunned that any prosecutor
would move forward with this it's even
flimsier than we were led to believe 34
stack counts bootstrapped to an unstated
crime to manufacture felony charges and
look at this headline fake news CNN when
would I ever quote them as a source
exactly approach I love this crowd not
exactly a pro-trump organization quote
why the Manhattan D.A case against Trump
is so pathetically weak and here's the
left-wing website vox.com they're not a
fan of mine anyway Bragg built one of
the most controversial high-profile
criminal cases in American history upon
the most uncertain of Foundations and
that Foundation could crumble into dust
and then there's this headline from the
New York slimy times the Trump
indictment is a legal embarrassment wow
wow I know right even the New York Times
gets it right once in a while
meanwhile on TV you got the media mob
they were visibly disappointed liberal
Joe and Company I thought they were
going to cry take a look
that indictment landed like uh like a
dud right for this to take the historic
step of being the first indictment of a
former president I think it's a bit
disappointing how not strong it is maybe
one of the greater weaknesses is how the
felony charges will hold up when they
are challenged by Mr Trump's defense
attorneys whether or not these election
law violations will truly result in
felony charges if they want to argue
that those documents were falsified in
furtherance of something that is a
federal election law violation that's
shaky legal ground I worry I mean look
if this is the only Pebble that gets
thrown at Donald Trump uh it's a very
small pebble in terms of a case that's
being brought against a former president
it's a little underwhelming all right
it's not only professional Talking Heads
listen to these Democratic voters from a
recent focus group take a look at this
they were building this and building
this I mean this is there's got to be
something but there has to be something
big and quite frankly look I'm not a fan
of Donald Trump but I was expecting more
I mean this is nothing new every
president everybody who gets ascended to
political power has some sort of
skeleton in their closet right so I
frankly wasn't that surprised my whole
thing is they found the worst prosecutor
in America to prosecute Trump people
they're they're buying power their
disposable income is shrinking you know
that's a lot of concern for us to be
worried about Finance laws uh on the
former president I think we're
concentrating on the wrong thing and it
this may backfire now no doubt there are
a lot of serious problems with Bragg's
Witch Hunt in this case but the most
egregious part of this case involves
what Bragg omitted from the indictment
as Rolling Stone was pointing out quote
Alvin Bragg's case against Trump is
still a mystery we don't even know what
the crime is he mentioned is a crime
that he doesn't tell us what it is now
keep in mind the document infractions
they're bootstrapped to an underlying
felony in fact this entire case hinges
on that underlying undefined felony but
Bragg doesn't feel the need to tell
anybody about the purported crime that
serves as the foundation of his entire
case it's not even listed in the
indictment as is required by the
Constitution look at your sixth
amendment it commands at the state
informed defendants about the nature of
the charges and the evidence against
them according to the New York Times
quote given only partial notice well
that might be standard operating
procedure in Manhattan but that standard
procedure suddenly in the bright lights
yesterday seemed like systemic
infringement believe it or not the
constitution of this country applies to
every American even though there are
Democrats and leftists that want to
shred it even New Yorkers even his Royal
Highness Alvin Bragg himself now don't
forget the Constitution mandates equal
protection under the law equal
application of our laws no man no woman
should be above the law but no one
should be below the law either and all
Americans deserve Equal justice and
equal application so when Bragg jumps
through hoops to connect Trump to a
far-fetched campaign Finance violation
or some other underlying unstated crime
because of a mislabeled NDA well let's
remember how Democrats were treated
under similar circumstances let's look
at Bill and Hillary Clinton and Barack
Obama and Sheila Jackson Lee and Martin
O'Malley and so many others connected to
very serious campaign Finance violations
none of them ever ever ever ever charged
with any crime just like Biden was not
raided none of his four locations of top
secret documents uh just like Hillary
Clinton got away with the leading
subpoenaed emails 33 thousand and
destroying devices with hammers and of
course removing SIM cards and don't
forget Jim Comey said that dossier is
verified but earlier in the month before
he signed it uh his own agents went to
Christopher Steele offered him a million
dollars to corroborate it he couldn't
collect his million dollars how come Jim
Comey gets to celebrate the indictment
of Donald Trump when in fact in my view
my humble view I'm not a lawyer he
should be indicted hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else